foreign
why are we doing this well it's it's for
the uh the Abigail Thorn video no
no
I know but this isn't
I mean I shot in this room before I've
never done this angle
I I don't I don't
I don't dress like this for this for
these videos yeah but it's more in the
spirit of like what she does I it's
never gonna look like I'm actually
matching her though it's gonna it's not
even gonna look like a cheap imitate
well like we this is this is a stupid
idea oh look we we could just reset and
go again I mean the whole thing's
probably a stupid idea but like this in
particular this is a hot this is stop
stop turn it off foreign
[Music]
I feel a little bit more relaxed now I'm
not taking the makeup off I look cute
so
I
have made a decision
I am going to watch Abigail Thorne's
play
the prince
the fact that it was a decision that
took me so long to make though
I feel like that's something I kind of
have to talk through
before anything else
because
I am a fan of Abigail Thorne I should
probably explain who she
explained who she is she does 20 times
my audience but sure why not
Abigail Thorne is a YouTuber a podcaster
a professional actress and now also a
playwright she runs the YouTube channel
philosophy tube she's quite well known
and I've enjoyed and admired her work
for
I guess about four years now
I very much enjoy what she does and it
it's actually probably worth
pausing that thought before I get any
further to explain a little bit about my
YouTube media diet because
I do watch a fair amount of YouTube
the thing is though I don't watch that
many people whose presentation and
content is especially similar to mine
there's
discomfort's not the word
but there's an oddness when I see
someone doing something that is
effectively the same thing that I do
and I can get one of a few things about
it I can get judgmental about it if I
find myself thinking I could do that
better I could end up with a sense of
professional jealousy if it's someone
doing something very similar to me who
appears to be far more successful with
it and that can be doubly so if I think
that there's some significant problems
with their work
this is part of why
I don't watch a lot of YouTubers
I talk about Doctor Who more than
anything else
I don't watch that much content from
other people who talk about Doctor Who
I'd watch some I'm subscribed to a
number I've I would consider myself
friends with a few of them even but I
don't watch a lot of it because
I can't detach what I do from what they
do and it hampers The Experience if only
because even if I'm not being judgmental
or jealous of what I'm seeing there's a
part of my brain that's going okay but
if I was tackling this topic how would I
do it this is actually a little bit of a
larger scope problem I think with lots
of people in Creative Fields you know
it's been an issue for me when I've gone
to plays and whether it be
professionally put on or Community
Theater
I had to go at acting and I can get a
little bit judgmental if I feel that the
play whether it be the staging the
performances or even the play itself
because I have written plays also
um I can get very judgmental about it
especially given that my own attempts at
that stalled out now is that fair to the
work I'm watching no
no that's a general rule probably not
but I can't completely turn off that
part of my brain
and so when I watch YouTube the content
that I tend to appreciate the most is
either stuff that is talking about
subjects that I would never cover or
it's giving a form of presentation that
I would never do either I never would
have the uh means and the ambition to
try and do or it would never occur to me
to do
so that's where I end up watching well
when it comes to hoodoo the mo the one I
watch most reliably is too bagful whose
work is exceptionally sarcastic and
occasionally kind of dark and uses
um these little stick figures uh for a
fair bit of it and I do consider a stu
to be a friend and I'd never ever
present my feelings on Doctor Who the
way he does and it makes it easier for
me to watch what he does
but then there are also of course people
who just everything about what they do
is unlike what I do I'm a huge fan of
Yahtzee croshaw of zero punctuation
I would never occur to me nor would I
ever have the ability to do what he does
so it makes it incredibly digestible but
even people who have a certain amount of
crossover with what I do be it in format
or topic if it is done at such a level
that I'm like
even if I tried to do it it would never
be that good that can actually kind of
quiet my brain a little bit
that's kind of the basis under which I
watch uh most of my friend Jesse genders
stuff because she goes in at a depth and
a editing ability and a
um presentation that I
I can't do that
like I don't have the time of the spoons
in my life and even if I did I don't
think I could do it that well
so I can ease off that and I enjoy
Abigail's work on YouTube on the same
basis
she goes in very deep on philosophical
topics in a way that even if I
understood the philosophy uh all that
well I wouldn't think to present it that
way so that kind of is the best of both
worlds in terms of me being able to
enjoy something it's both a subject that
I wouldn't tackle on my own and present
it in a way that I would never think to
or be able to match
that doesn't mean that I watch your
stuff immediately when it comes out it
tends to be very thinky and I sometimes
need to be in the right headspace to be
prepared to digest whatever it is I'm
going to be taking in she's not the only
one that I feel that way about there's a
number of really good video essays that
I tend to sit on their stuff for a few
days or weeks or months even because I'm
like I gotta be in the right headspace
if I'm gonna try and take this in
but that's been my relationship with her
work up to this point
so why have I been hesitant
to watch the prince
well I think there's a couple of things
at play there
and I want to talk them through
the first is that
well
as I mentioned before
I'm also a playwright
I've written a play
it hasn't been staged so far as I'm
aware I suppose that's theoretically
possible it's available for purchase on
Amazon somebody could have bought it and
staged it but if anyone has I don't know
and I seriously doubt it part of the
reason I just published it was because I
was not able even with ties to theater
organizations around where I live I was
not able to get it staged and just
broadly speaking um nobody came back and
said it's not good enough it was an
issue of this content isn't going to
play right for our audience uh we don't
know if uh we could find a director or
actress who would be comfortable with it
or something like that because it's I
mean
an exploration of BDSM and 2x is it's
literally the subtitles so you know I
get it
but
the thing is that for as different as
her work is from what I do in terms of
her YouTube output there's
more than a little similarity
between Abigail and myself
I didn't mention the fact up to now that
Abigail is a trans woman because
honestly it wasn't especially relevant
until I got to the point of talking
about our similarities
because
we both after having a
some degree of having established a
brand and identity on YouTube came out
as trans feminine a trans woman in her
case a trans Femme gender fluid in mine
we both have gone at acting
we both create stuff on YouTube
obviously
we both
have now written a play
and the thing is
she's had more success than me in every
single one of these things
and has done so being not a significant
number of years younger than I am
and so that question of professional
jealousy comes up again
but I don't
know why it's here now
and maybe it isn't even
because part of me just wonders am I
just worried that people will read it
that way because if I watch this play
and I don't like it
will it be interpreted as me being
professionally jealous
because she's now entered into one more
area that I tried to do playwriting and
has seen success in it that I have not
and probably never will
but I haven't been jealous of her
success up to this point at least I
don't think so
but I am still worried about that
being thought of me
if I don't like it
but then that brings the question
why am I afraid
that I won't like it
I've liked to varying degrees pretty
much all of her work that I've taken in
whether it be on YouTube or it be the
podcast kill James Bond that she's a
part of I've enjoyed her work fairly
reliably and when I have taken in works
by other creators that is outside of
what I primarily am used to digesting
from them I haven't been this kind of
nervous
Stu bagfold put out an anthology of
podcasts that I listened to happily and
I wasn't worried about not liking them
Yahtzee croshaw I've I was going to say
read his books I've listened to his
audiobooks of his novels and I wasn't
afraid I wasn't going to like them I was
just prepared to take them in
but I'm genuinely worried
about not liking the prince
and part of that
is
tied to wondering what people will think
of me if I don't like it
but there's something other than that
too
because I wasn't really that nervous
about it
until she described the premise in one
of her videos
and I let her use her own words to do so
and I have written a play
it's called the prince it's about a
bunch of characters in a Shakespeare
play Who start to realize that they're
all stuck inside of play once I heard
that
I started to worry that I wasn't going
to like it now
I want to be clear that General premise
that sort of meta narrative is not
inherently a problem it's not even
something that I have an inherent
dislike of by any means
however
as someone who has been doing varying
degrees of creative writing since I'd
say middle school with reliability and
who since high school actually no since
middle school again have been engaged in
various playwriting workshops
I was involved in that in middle school
high school into college honestly if I
had just been a freaking theater major
like I should have been I might have
actually finished college but that's a
whole other conversation
I have not dealt a lot not only with my
own Journey I'm trying to express myself
through the medium play but I've been
around a lot of other people doing the
same thing and as well as people doing
short films and the reason I bring up
short films is because there tends to be
a bit of overlap between
what
uh playwrights do early into their
attempts at playwriting and what
short filmmakers do not uh technically
from a technical sense it's very
different but in terms of the narratives
they tend to pick
and
I'm sorry I'm really sorry
but a play about characters who realize
that they're in a play
it's kind of a basic playwright 101 kind
of plot
like everybody does this I don't know a
single person who has tried to pursue in
some way playwriting or filmmaking or
even sketches who hasn't done some
version of this this is what everybody
does and that's not even a problem it
doesn't preclude it from being bad but
it just makes it such a basic premise in
my mind
and not to mention the fact that it's
the kind of premise that lends itself to
pretentious wankery
not always
but sometimes
I
there are things that do this there are
stories that do this there's a play that
does this that I like very much it's
called Rosencrantz and Dylan's Turner
are dead and I love it but I strongly
suspect part of the reason I love it was
because I discovered it when I was 13
and the concept blew my mind for the
first freaking time I think if I were to
try and take in Rosencrantz and
gillenstone are dead be it the play or
the movie now maybe I'd still enjoy it
but not to the same extent because
yeah it's your spin on this thing that
literally every playwright gets excited
about because they think they're the
first person who freaking thought of it
and they're not
you can see the frustration
bubble up
because look the prince
may be brilliant and it's worth
emphasizing as I record this I haven't
seen it yet
this is not typical for me I'm giving
you extensive rambling thoughts about me
and my thought process and try to purse
my own Brain before I even see it
because if I watch this thing well not
if when I'm going to when I watch this
thing
if it turns out that all my fears just
wash away I don't know if I'll be able
to still talk about them I have to talk
about them now
while they're fresh
while they're in my head and I'm feeling
the feelings
because I don't know if I'll be able to
recall all this after the fact
and
I need to talk through
why I'm afraid
to take in the prince
but coming back to that idea that it's
kind of a basic premise
that does not preclude it from being
good
one of my favorite things to do in any
medium is to take in something that
knowing the basic setup of it I think
that's not going to work
I don't see how that can work and then
loving it
this past year the Batman did that for
me I am so beyond sick of dark and
gritty brooding brutal Batman I was
convinced that maybe I would come out
going it's a good movie I still don't
like it I liked it a lot
and that was wonderful
I there are a few things that I love
more than going into something that I'm
pretty dang sure I won't like and going
oh hey
that was good
and I can hope for that but I also have
to acknowledge it's a minority opinion
that I end up having if that is what
pans out because at this point I'm
pretty good at having a sense of whether
or not I'm gonna like something ahead of
watching it it's why I like when I do
things like a top 10 at the end of the
year I only talk about the best stuff I
don't do a worst list because I don't
make myself watch stuff that I think I
won't like
so when I do that list I'll give a
dishonorable mention the most
disappointing which was something I
thought I would like and didn't because
that's kind of all that applies
it's very rare for me to watch something
or take something in or read it or
whatever that I think I probably won't
like this
but every now and then sometimes when I
do
and sometimes out of a sense of
obligation like with the Batman I get
pleasantly surprised
but I'm still nervous
to watch the prince
I'm gonna make an odd comparison here
because another YouTuber significantly
larger than I am who I like quite a bit
uh and should give you a taste of the
odd range of my enjoyments is TomSka
best known for the uh animated sketch
series active movie
he also has a secondary Channel called
tomskon friends and on that there was a
series he does with two of his friends
called try Hearts where they uh pick up
something to try and do and they give a
certain amount of time then they come
back and see how everybody did with it
and they did one last year that was
short films and after they were done
they put those online and had a little
Festival you know local to where they
were
and I watched Toms and it was probably
the best produced but it was a character
realizing that they're fictional and
eventually devolving into a case of well
the creator of this the writer has
writer's block and the reason this
doesn't make sense is because the writer
doesn't know where he's going can't
figure out what he's doing and it ends
with the lead character killing the
author
um
that wouldn't bother me so much if not
for the fact that Tom is on record as
loathing student films like pretentious
student films and it has instilled such
a lifelong hatred of student films and
student film tropes I never got over
though I'm still upset I'm still bitter
and I'm watching this going Tom
if I were to try and think generically
what is the most student film premise I
could think of it's literally what you
just did
for all the years that I've taken in you
know various uh you know festivals of
plays workshops and plays other stuff I
have read and seen and heard so many
people do this I've done it I wrote this
freaking thing and I did it 15 years ago
but like
ah
it was frustrating
now I didn't have a lot of investment in
that frustration time I was just like oh
Tom come on I moved on
but something worries me
about having that frustration towards
Abigail
so why am I afraid to watch the prince
there is an odd thing
that I came to realize
in thinking about this and realizing I
needed to talk it through
which is
it's not just
that I want
to enjoy Abigail's the prince
I need to
I need it
to be not only good
but great
but why
why does that matter
because it has nothing to do with my
opinion of her
I don't know her
I mean I know her work been watching her
for years even supported her on patreon
for a little bit before I kind of
stopped supporting anybody on patreon
because I can't really afford it anymore
but
why would something that has nothing to
do with me
and like even if it's a premise that I
don't like I can't imagine it's going to
lower my opinion of her
why do I need this to be great
it has nothing to do with her
and everything to do with me
and my sense of
my own creative worth
and to a certain extent yes that is
professional jealousy but it's
something a little different
something a little
more Twisted than that
I'm comfortable watching Abigail's work
because as I said before it is done at
such a high level
I don't need to compare myself to her
I can't do what she does
not the conception of it the writing of
it the performance of it the production
values of it I mean aside from the fact
that flatly I can't afford to even try
and do that but even if I could I don't
think I could do that
but I've written a play
a play that I am
still very very proud of
that nobody has seen
and very few people have read
and so if I take in the prince
and I don't like it
and for the first time
I find myself thinking
I could have done that better
then the critical eye
turns in on myself
what am I doing wrong
that I don't
have
that level of success that I can't
get my foot in the door
how am I holding myself
back
what
failures do I have
that have stopped me from having that
success
when she can write and have produced and
get to star in a play
and its pretentious wankery
and I have to self-publish my book my
novel
my play
beg for patreon support because I barely
cover my bills
if she's not better at this than I am
then why
is she where she's at
and I'm back here
none of that is fair
none of that is rational
and none of that has anything to do with
her
part of what gets me going and keeps me
going day to day is a certain amount of
trust that I'm going about what I do in
the way that works best for me and I am
covering my bills barely but I am
covering my bills
and that in itself
is the privilege
that is
enough
I need it to be enough
because it's what I have
and I can't
expect much more than that
I can hope for it strive for it
but
most of what I do has plateaued
growth on this channel
the patreon
so forth
this might be as far as I go
and
part of what can make me more
comfortable with that idea
is that the people who have gone farther
are better and more skilled
well there's no shame in being beaten by
the best but he didn't see more than we
were beaten by the best I don't just
want that to be true I need that to be
true
because if it's not
then my work
a growth
my support stagnating
is my fault
that's also irrational
that's also not true
because there's a ton of other factors
Abigail has footholds and contacts in
the actual professional theater
Community my contacts were in community
theater and like one of two professional
people who only kinda knew me
I don't have those points of contact
I don't
have a lot of what she has and despite
the comparisons I made before what we do
is fundamentally very different she does
40 minute hour long videos about deep
philosophical context Concepts while
doing all of this a wonderful sometimes
bizarre well-performed presentation ice
in front of a wall of toys and talk
about Doctor Who
what are you doing
that you compare yourself to her is what
I want to do I want to shake myself and
yell that
but I do it anyway
and it didn't matter until the prince
because I look at what she does and I
look at what I do and I go it's not the
same thing it's fine
and so
I
am and have been scared
to watch the prince
but I need to get over it
and that means
stopping this video
signing up
for nebula who is not sponsoring this to
be clear and
seeing the professional record
so that's what I'm gonna do
I've talked through my weird irrational
emotional
self-critical reasons for being
conflicted about this I've done that now
which means it's time
just to watch it
be back in a bit
laughs
it's not there
it's
it's not on the surface yet
because of how long she's been talking
about this and knowing that the play has
been staged um and like it's got
nominated for stuff I assume that the
professional record had already happened
and was on I'd be like but it's not
there yet they're still editing it
I don't even know what is gonna go up
this right now is just q1
[Music]
I can't even watch it yet
foreign
all that
all done
to build up
and I can't even see it yet
I'll probably get around to it when it
comes out
and like
how much you want to bet I just sum it
up as like a community poster tweet
[Laughter]
what what even is this what did I what
did I make
what did I produce
oh my God
[Music]
if you're still here
why
but
I don't even know
at the end of my videos I say what are
your thoughts on what I've talked about
I don't even know what I've talked about
I don't know what this was
but I'll tell you what
it's not something Abigail would have
produced
whatever thoughts on whatever this was
that you want to share
drop something down in the comments
let's
figure out what the hell I did
foreign
look all the usual stuff you know the
plugs you've been on YouTube there's
links below for whatever's you know
stuff
oh
just try and remember
because I need to try and remember
sometimes that
regardless of whatever self-critical
nonsense voice
has given you such blinders that you
don't even bother to check if
something's available for you to see yet
regardless of any of that
you're beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just I was gonna
say I'm just running the meetings I just
I'm just doing nonsense at this point I
don't even know what I'm doing but until
next time this council is unsure
foreign
supporter Shout Out Time folks so thank
you to Robin Moore Zubin lupula to rock
the thing that goes doink in the anime
Oliver B Angus bjornison Linda Walters
IMU delki Theo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
spark for knobby lacks the poodle Zach
Tracy scrabot General contact unit
Problem Child angry Casper Tim price
Adam RDL Taylor Shayla Gourley and
Brendan liberals thanks so much for your
help you can get your name right out too
check out the rewards in the patreon
is that what they should do should they
check the patreon
[Music]